Quién es el rey Eduardo
séptimo es el bisabuelo de la Reina
Isabel su apodo es el pacificador
tras el fallecimiento de la Reina Isabel
II la liga monárquica de Canadá está
intensificando sus esfuerzos para
promover la corona pero muchos que
beckensa se muestran indiferentes a su
nuevo Rey Carlos III
es muy importante que el rey venga a
Canadá lo más a menudo posible la
monarquía necesita ser vista por la
gente para que entienda su papel su
importancia y su relevancia y comprenda
que esta conexión Todavía existe
esa conexión no existe para muchos
quebequenses que ven a la monarquía como
una imposición un ejemplo es el mucha
increíble
mostró que el 77% de los quebequenses
consideran que la monarquía es inútil me
tiene completamente diferente no
ninguna opinión al respecto no me
molestan absoluto que la tengamos en un
Home Depot la monarquía es como es
genial es histórica pero realmente no le
veo valor en una especie de sociedad
moderna como la nuestra especialmente
una fundada en la igualdad entonces
podría la monarquía estar acercándose a
su desaparición según la Constitución
canadiense es necesario el
consentimiento unánime del senado la
cámara de los comunes y todas las
provincias
si hablamos de Justin trudeau o incluso
de su principal oponente pierpo ayer
apoyan a la monarquía a nivel Federal no
es realmente un partido político que se
Centre en rechazar la monarquía como
vemos en Australia Así que es poco
probable que se produzca el
derrocamiento de la monarquía
en otros países de la comuna nuez como
jamaica y Australia Hay un gran deseo de
emancipación al igual que en Barbados
cuando hace menos de un año se convirtió
en una república